[Musique]
étranger
[Musique
] [
Musique] [Musique]
Lake District Lake
District [
Musique] [
Musique]
fascino
est étranger [
Musique]
perturbation sous l'eau à
environ un pied sous l'eau je dirais
et c'était comme un  une sorte de
mouvement de barattage sous l'eau de
manière horizontale pouvait sentir que le bateau
allait basculer d'un côté à l'autre ou avoir
un impact dessus
c'était vraiment trois morceaux j'ai en quelque sorte vu
environ trois morceaux dans l'eau
le type classique de  Forme du Loch Ness
J'ai paniqué parce que je suis dans l'eau je suis
seul et je sens qu'il y a quelque chose là-bas ce qui
va se passer
je le décrirais comme un monstre marin
euh avec un grand corps un long cou et une
petite tête voyageant très vite donc  rapide
que l'eau blanche se détachait
des bosses et qu'elle se dirigeait vers le nord en
remontant le lac j'ai vu quelque chose dans l'eau
si c'était un monstre je ne sais pas
mais j'ai définitivement vu quelque chose dans l'
eau c'était long c'était noir ça  se
déplaçait dans l'eau
euh ce que c'était réellement Je laisserai
les autres déterminer la pédialyse
le
bonus des descriptions est le village principal sur le lac
ici à windsmere
[Musique]
lorsque le journal local a rapporté pour la première fois la
première observation du monstre
euh ils ont pris  le nom d'une
légende écossaise un folklore en Ecosse où sur le
Loch Nessa se trouve un monstre connu sous le nom de Nessie
alors ils ont mis les deux noms ensemble et ont
trouvé l'os Essie qui a pris
très rapidement dans l'imagination populaire
le bonus a été considéré comme vraiment une
forme sombre  dans les eaux de Windermere,
en général, nous pensons qu'elle ou il pourrait mesurer
peut-être 20 ou 30 mètres de long avec des bosses
et une sorte de forme de monstre traditionnelle
est
[Musique] la
première observation a eu lieu en juillet 2006. c'était
fin juillet, il faisait chaud  l'été c'était
un bon été nous étions en train de déjeuner avec
des amis qui restaient juste
à côté de la maison douaire à côté du
château de Ray et avons décidé d'aller nous promener
après le déjeuner
[Musique]
et nous avons marché jusqu'à quel point de terrier
et nous avons bavardé  et j'ai entendu Steve
parler de quelque chose dans l'eau et
il pointait du doigt et au début je n'ai pas
fait attention, puis il a dit où est
mon appareil photo
oh
je le regardais depuis le
promontoire alors j'étais peut-être sur le point de
ne pas '  Je ne sais pas à 20 mètres de lui, peut-être
même plus près, je suis vraiment très proche
et il était clair que c'était une
créature vivante et j'étais ce qui m'a le
plus surpris, je pense, ce n'était pas seulement de
le voir, mais c'était la vitesse à laquelle  il
voyageait il n'y avait aucune sorte de battement
ou quoi que ce soit ce n'était pas comme un poisson
il allait comme une torpille donc c'est
clairement ce n'était rien d'autre
qu'une créature vivante
Tout s'est passé très vite à
cause de la vitesse  à laquelle il
voyageait et dans
je ne sais pas
20 secondes ou quelque chose comme ça, il était en haut
du lac
dans ce lac, pour
autant que je sache, j'ai donc été la première personne
à vraiment le voir. L'histoire est apparue
dans la Westland Gazette en août
2006, puis l'histoire a été
reprise par de nombreux médias à la fois nationaux
et internationaux, il semblait  pour faire
le tour du monde, quelqu'un m'a dit que
très tôt c'était dans l'
un des grands journaux nationaux indiens
et j'ai entendu dire
que euh vous savez que c'est maintenant en quelque sorte
entré dans les livres de voyage à l'étranger c'est devenu
un
c'est  devenir une sorte de
fait établi si vous aimez qu'il y ait quelque chose
ici
Lyndon Adams est
[Musique]
Linden Adams étranger
ouais près de là où nous sommes maintenant sur la
route derrière nous
euh c'est là que j'ai filmé quelques plans d'une
perturbation dans l'eau  dont je
ne pouvais pas expliquer
la nature de mon tournage ce jour-là était de
sortir sur le lac pour voir si nous pouvions
capturer des images d'une créature que Lyndon
Adams avait photographiée depuis
la maison de Gummer pour filmer
ce que les gens ont maintenant surnommé bonessi
[Musique]
donc
les photos que j'ai prises étaient les photos d'établissement
du lac c'était un
temps clair c'était légèrement couvert mais
l'eau était calme et la perturbation que
j'ai vue, je pensais qu'elle venait du
ferry local, alors j'ai arrêté d'enregistrer
plus tard quand j'ai parlé à  un boulonneur local,
euh, il a souligné que le ferry était un
mile plus loin sur le lac, donc cela ne pouvait pas
être ce genre de perturbation,
il ne pouvait pas l'expliquer et moi non plus
et je n'ai pas eu une bonne explication de
ce que le  les images sont
[Music]
Je pense que dans l'ensemble, la plupart des habitants sont
sceptiques après avoir dit que lorsque le
journal local a mené une enquête en ligne au
moment de je pense que c'était l'une des
observations ultérieures il y a peut-être deux ou trois
ans, ils ont mené une enquête en ligne et
a dit juste une question très simple
croyez-vous au bonus oui ou non et c'était
absolument 50 50 et c'était parmi
leur lectorat qui sont pour la plupart des locaux
mon expérience est qu'il y a un poisson qui
vit là depuis des milliers d'années que
les gens ont expérimenté ils '  Je ne l'ai jamais fait
sortir dans la
communauté par peur du ridicule par peur
du rire la peur d'être pris pour un
imbécile
eh bien je peux vous dire à partir de maintenant alors au
large de Falls il y a quelque chose là-dedans
je classerais Bon Essie comme un grand
mammifère  préhistorique peut-être qui est
à Windermere depuis un certain nombre
d'années
et il nous choisit simplement pour être vus par
diverses personnes de temps en temps, il y
a eu diverses observations au cours des
deux dernières années et quelques
très crédibles
moi-même et Thomas avons eu  une rencontre
avec eux et d'autres personnes locales ont
également eu des rencontres au cours des années précédentes
[Musique] [
Musique]
Je décris le Lake District
comme les Grands Lacs d'Amérique mais
plus petit comme les montagnes de
Suisse mais sous forme miniature et
c'est un One-  Arrêtez
l'expérience de voyage, ils peuvent venir ici,
ils peuvent tout visiter en une semaine
au lieu de voyager à travers le
pays
quatre semaines ou mois et ici et ici, c'est
juste avec les villages et c'est
intact, c'est vous savez que c'est
beau de peut-être si nous  étaient ici il
y a 300 ans et je suis assis ici c'est
exactement le même point de vue que vous auriez
[Musique]
étranger
J'ai eu
une
réunion assez sérieuse avec bonusi il y a
quelques années
en préparation d'une nage dans la Manche que j'avais  Je me suis
engagé et nous avons dû nous
entraîner et la meilleure façon de nous entraîner est dans
le lac mais aussi le lac est plein de
trafic de bateaux vous avez des skieurs nautiques
vous avez les ferries c'est juste l'
activité constante
alors nous avons décidé que ça commencerait
nager tôt le matin salut compagnie Thomas
à travers le Royaume-Uni et l'Europe sur diverses
nages longue distance qu'il a
rencontrées Je les entraîne et garde un œil
sur lui quand il nage aussi la
chose la plus importante quand je
nage avec Thomas est l'
aspect sécurité garder  un œil sur lui constamment
et en veillant à ce que s'il rencontrait des
difficultés, je puisse le pêcher
immédiatement hors de l'eau,
nous avons eu une rencontre très inhabituelle au début
d'un centre commercial de juillet et il y a quelques années
lors de l'entraînement avec Thomas sur League
Windermere et  ce bâtiment particulier
c'était 5 45
et c'était un miroir c'était comme un miroir
le lac était magnifique on pouvait voir les
montagnes à l'envers c'était une
image parfaite et je ne voulais vraiment pas
sauter dedans et gâcher la tranquillité
du  du lac,
nous nous dirigeons
vers
une zone juste en face de l'hôtel Langdale Chase
appelée les profondeurs qui est la
partie la plus profonde du lac Windermere ça
s'appelle les profondeurs et ça a un très et
ça me fait peur aussi et
j'ai nagé tout  de haut en bas du lac, mais
dès que quelqu'un a mentionné les profondeurs, une
nounou nageuse dont vous avez besoin parce qu'il
y a ce Mystique à ce sujet,
alors je suis entré, j'ai nagé et j'ai fait ce que je
fais normalement,
puis j'ai éteint et juste  laisser la
mécanique de mon coup
me faire traverser l'autre côté du lac
Thomas nageait il était dans
son petit monde je planifiais ma journée
nous parlons à cinq heures du
matin je planifiais ma journée ce dont j'avais
besoin  à faire à l'hôtel après cela, je
nageais et puis tout d'un coup, nous avons
eu une petite rencontre,
senti cette poussée massive me dépasser
et d'abord et avant tout, j'ai pensé que c'était
un gros poisson, puis j'ai pensé qu'il aurait pu
été un hors-bord avec un
skieur nautique à l'arrière et j'ai pensé avec
tout le lac avec les seuls ici
pourquoi venir si près de nous et cela m'a fait paniquer
ensuite, le bateau dans lequel je faisais du canoë
à l'époque a basculé de  côté côté maintenant
je me fais sortir du bateau,
il était secoué et ensuite
j'ai été soulevé et tombé
comme un cadavre
et j'ai regardé autour de moi, je ne pouvais rien voir
et je pouvais voir l'inquiétude
sur son visage et j'ai dit  pour lui, qu'est-ce que c'était que
ça et il était
sans voix en regardant le lac?
Mary Celeste
j'ai dit revenons j'ai été secoué et
j'ai été choqué et j'ai dit que je viens de
vivre quelque chose que je ne pense pas que
personne ne m'ait cru ici bonus qu'il était et
j'ai dû le sentir
beaucoup de gens au fil des ans ont dit  pour
nous des choses différentes ou n'était-ce pas des
bateaux à moteur n'y avait-il pas tant de ski nautique sur
le lac nous parlons à cinq heures
du matin c'était un Corner Lake plat c'était
comme du verre il n'y avait pas d'âme à propos
d'où pourquoi  nous le cultivons si tôt
après cette expérience, je suis un vrai
croyant, le lac Windermere est
[musique]
étranger [
musique]
avant les croisières sur le lac,
nous exploitons 16 bateaux à passagers sur
Windermere et ces bateaux auront un
équipage variant de deux sur les plus petits
bateaux  à un équipage de sept personnes, donc j'ai
probablement environ 40 capitaines et ils
passent toute leur journée de travail sur le lac,
nous naviguons 364 jours par an tout au
long de la journée, donc du
matin jusqu'à tard le soir,
nous avons  J'ai des skippers et des équipages sur le
lac pour regarder Surveiller les
autres bateaux, les autres embarcations et tout ce qui se trouve
dans le puits
Je travaille pour l'entreprise depuis
environ 18 ans, donc je conduis
ces bateaux
depuis environ 12 ans à plein temps  sur ici donc
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps sur les jambes
il y a vous savez quatre Skippers à plein temps
sur ces bateaux nous passons environ 2
000 heures par an sur le lac je n'ai jamais
vu un autre lac que vous ne vous
attendriez pas à avoir  une liste d'animaux que je
vois nager dans le lac que vous
ne vous attendriez pas à voir dans le lac mais je
sais ce qu'ils sont il
y a un faisan un fou de Bassan un écureuil
et un cerf de mon temps ici ce sont les
quatre animaux que vous voudriez  Je ne m'attends pas à
voir dans le lac
mais je pourrais les identifier peut-être qu'ils
veulent croire qu'il y a quelque chose
ici et ils pensent peut-être qu'ils le font ouais
comme un jour le jour avec beaucoup de façons
de voir des ondulations dans le lac qu'ils pourraient
interpréter  être une créature, mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose en quoi j'ai jamais cru, je n'ai
entendu que des descriptions d'autres
personnes et en tant que batelier, nous gardons beaucoup les pieds
sur terre ou sur le
pont du bateau, nous devons donc voir les choses par nous-
mêmes  yeux vraiment pour le croire alors peut-être que
je ne suis pas seulement le bon gars pour demander
merci
c'est un fait pour moi s'il y a eu
huit observations qui ne me convainquent pas
que cela existe ma propre observation m'a convaincu
parce que je sais absolument ce que je  vu,
vous savez, j'ai vu une créature vivante qui
voyageait très longtemps très vite et cela
ne ressemblait à rien de ce que j'avais jamais vu. Je
ne ressemblais certainement à rien qui
devrait vivre dans ce lac que
quiconque ait jamais enregistré,
donc pour moi  -site me convainc
absolument et gardez à l'esprit que j'ai une
formation de journaliste donc vous savez que
je suis un peu sceptique sur la plupart des choses
je suis sceptique sur les choses jusqu'à ce que je puisse
prouver qu'elles sont vraies mais je dois
croire la mienne  mes propres sens je l'ai fait je l'ai
vu
je suis né et j'ai grandi en bonus sur
Windermere quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai travaillé
sur les ronds-points sur le lac et
nous étions tous les jours d'été sur le
lac lui-même dans les ronds-points
les fatiguant à  touristes
et pour être honnête, nous n'avons jamais
rien vu de mystérieux dans ou sur
le lac autre que les touristes et mon
sentiment est qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de quoi s'inquiéter là-bas, mais
évidemment je pourrais me tromper
[Music]
la présence
est spectaculaire
[Musique]
la première observation a eu lieu en 2006, soit
12 mois après
que
la limite de vitesse soit entrée
en vigueur sur le lac, donc le lac était un
endroit beaucoup plus calme
pendant 12 mois, il n'y avait pas eu de
bateaux rapides, donc tout ce qui avait peut-être
vécu au  fond du lac ou dans
les profondeurs de l'eau
aurait pu se sentir encouragé à se montrer
[Musique]
répréhensible
ma préférée est vraiment assez simple
elle a commencé à apparaître parce que le lac est
maintenant calme tu sais qu'elle n'est pas effrayée
par cette constante  le bruit peut-être dans le
passé, il apparaissait la
nuit quand il n'y avait personne autour, mais maintenant
parce que le lac est calme,
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il apparaît
quoi qu'il en soit, je pense qu'il apparaît
à cause de cela,
je suis un écologiste du lac du  centre d'
écologie et d'hydrologie et je
mène des recherches scientifiques sur
Windermere depuis 1990.
la plupart de mon travail personnel concerne
les populations de poissons du lac, mais
je travaille au sein d'un groupe de recherche qui
examine tous les aspects du lac de
ses éléments physiques de base de sa
chimie à travers son plancton et d'autres
petits animaux et jusqu'à la caractéristique des populations de poissons
[Musique]
du Lake District avait d'autres
lacs eux-mêmes, il n'y a nulle part ailleurs en
Angleterre qui a une telle diversité dans
un tel nombre de lacs et  alors
Windermere lui-même est le plus grand
lac naturel de toute l'Angleterre par sa superficie
et c'est aussi l'un des plus profonds,
il se peut donc qu'il y ait d'autres
espèces au fond du lac
parce que c'est une pièce d'eau si ancienne
et parce que  il est si vaste de
11 miles de long et en raison de sa
profondeur, il pourrait bien y avoir
des créatures euh des poissons de grande taille au
fond du lac qui n'ont pas été
vus
[Musique]
étranger
Windermere est habité par un certain nombre d'
espèces de poissons et l'un des  L'omble chevalier
est très localisé en Angleterre, c'est donc
une espèce assez rare. Nous avons également un grand
nombre de perches appelées gardons
et aussi des poissons appelés brochet et le
saumon atlantique et la truite brune
entreront également dans le lac, mais le
plus gros de ces poissons serait  être le brochet
ou le saumon et le plus gros individu que
nous verrions jamais aurait moins
d'un mètre de long, donc aucun des
poissons indigènes du lac ne pourrait
expliquer les
observations d'un très gros animal
ma meilleure idée de ce que l'os comme  vous
pensez que cela pourrait être s'il s'agit d'un animal plus gros
que le genre de choses que nous
connaissons dans le lac, ma meilleure hypothèse est
qu'il s'agit d'un gros poisson-chat qui a été
introduit une espèce qui n'est pas originaire
de cette partie du Royaume-Uni à coup sûr  et nous
savons que certains pêcheurs ont amené du
poisson-chat au Royaume-Uni à des fins de pêche,
mais ces poissons-chats, même dans les
régions indigènes du monde, ne deviennent pas
assez gros pour être le genre de taille que le bonus
est censé être, je ne vois aucune raison pourquoi  il
se peut qu'il n'y ait pas de créature hybride génétique
dans le lac, peut-être un très
gros rendement, un très gros poisson-chat
étranger
à ce que je pense qu'il pourrait y avoir et
ce que je pensais avant de nager sont deux
choses différentes si vous m'aviez demandé
avant mon  nager ce qu'il y avait là-dedans je
dirais de gros poissons de l'eau froide et
des bateaux
et à mon avis il y a des croyants
non croyants entre nous et
des gens dont vous savez que je
ne sortirais jamais avec ces histoires ont
vécu des choses différentes que ce soit en
haut  de l'eau au bord de l'
eau s'ils naviguent pas tellement en
nageant
ils ont vécu quelque chose de très
similaire maintenant nous ne pouvons pas tous nous tromper
certaines populations
et depuis lors avec les questions et
les demandes, les marins ont été là-bas qui
ils ont vu quelque chose
venir vers leurs bateaux et
rouler comme une tranche de viande puis
disparaître, cela fait que cela pourrait être
un vieux monstre péristaltique qui vit
au fond et se nourrit de poisson
le lac n'est pas surexploité il y a l'
étrange pêcheur  qui va là-bas
il n'y a pas de chalutiers
mais il manque de poissons et de nage
parfois à part les vieux poissons on ne voit
rien et au fond il y a de l'omble
mais les gens n'attrapent rien et il
n'y a pas de pollution dans leur lac il
fleurit avec tous les types d'
animaux sauvages  et ça demande juste ce qu'on mange
ou pourquoi un poisson n'est pas abondant
merci
[Music]
de populations [
Music]
la première observation a été faite par un gars
ici en vacances donc je l'ai vu dans notre
journal local et puis il
s'est avéré que  le souci du gentleman
était un conférencier en études des médias,
donc ma première réaction a été que ce type
menait une sorte de recherche
et plantait une histoire de monstre et
voyait comment les médias l'abordaient, c'était donc
la première fois que j'entendais ces ces derniers
des idées
étrangères,
la prochaine chose qui s'est produite a été que
des photos ont été prises par le
monstre par un photographe professionnel
et on m'a montré celles-ci avant qu'elles ne deviennent
publiques et ma première réaction en voyant
la première herbe a été qu'elles étaient en
effet de quelque chose de biologique
au milieu de  le lac quelque chose se déplaçant
autour de quelque chose de réel pas un
artefact mais de mon point de vue, ce que je
ne pouvais pas juger était la taille de cette
chose,
donc il m'a semblé que cela pourrait être juste
un cormoran ou une ponceuse gluante ou une loutre
même un  des cerfs nageant dans le lac
parfois vous avez des cerfs nageant
dans le lac les
touristes n'étaient
peut-être pas habitués à
être dans la région en voyant les lacs en
voyant les différentes ambiances du lac
car l'ambiance de la lumière peut changer
très rapidement
il y a beaucoup de choses différentes qui
peut arriver la lumière peut changer et la
houle peut se lever le vent vit à
différents endroits à différents moments il
peut être calme une minute et se lever assez
venteux le prochain
S étranger aussi bien projeter de très bonnes ombres
sur le lac
[Musique]
aussi il y a  beaucoup de bois autour du
lac, ce qui signifie qu'il est très difficile de
se rendre au bord du lac pour
vraiment le regarder et je pense que probablement les
deux tiers du lac sont
des bois privés et privés et des terres privées autour de
lui,
donc la plupart des gens vont  pour voir l'os SC
s'ils le voient d'assez loin et
je pense que vous constaterez qu'à part certains
canoéistes qui pensaient l'avoir vu
alors qu'ils étaient sur le lac
et la plupart des observations ont été faites depuis
les collines ou depuis un  à une bonne distance
[Music]
en tant que scientifique quand nous voyons des cheveux de Moore
cité ce que nous voulons désespérément, c'est une
preuve objective pour cela et de bonnes
photographies et il n'y a vraiment pas
eu de bonnes photographies donc c'est la même chose
qu'une histoire du Loch Ness c'est juste  ne
produit pas de
photographies décentes
étrangère
[Musique]
dans laquelle nous sortons dans le lac dans notre
navire de recherche et transmettons des impulsions
sonores cinq fois par seconde dans
l'eau que nous conduisons autour du lac sur un
ensemble et
un ensemble de  transects et nous enregistrons des choses
dans la colonne d'eau afin que nous puissions
compter les poissons et cela nous permet également d'évaluer la
taille de ces poissons et nous
le faisons une fois par mois et de jour comme de
nuit depuis 1990. et donc nous avons de bonnes
idées de  les changements dans le nombre de poissons
et les changements dans les tailles et
nous n'avons jamais rien vu de plus d'un
mètre environ, qui est la taille maximale d'
un saumon ou d'un brochet que nous verrions
d'autres personnes ont suggéré que
la chose  qui a été vu est vraiment une
loutre ou même une famille de loutres à
certaines périodes de l'année parce que les loutres
sont assez communes autour du
district des lacs là-bas beaucoup plus abondantes qu'elles ne l'
étaient il y a quelques années à peine et
existent certainement à Windermere et
autour de Windermere et  si vous avez vu
quelque chose dans l'eau et que vous vous méprenez sur
la taille de cet objet, une loutre
remplirait beaucoup de
descriptions qui ont été données
à certains moments de l'année,
la loutre femelle sera avec ses petits
donc  ils seront dans un groupe familial pour ainsi dire, donc
si vous êtes très chanceux, vous
pourriez voir un groupe de loutres se déplacer
ensemble sur le lac ou sur les bords
du lac, ce sont les loutres qui sont proches les unes des autres,
vous pourriez avoir l'impression
que  vous regardez une grande chose
plutôt qu'un certain nombre de petites choses
qui sont sur leur dos
[Musique]
d'un point de vue scientifique, je pense que
nous pouvons parler avec une autorité pour
Windermere parce que c'est le lac qui
a eu de loin le plus  étude scientifique
dans tout le Royaume-Uni, il y
a des scientifiques basés à Windermere
depuis les années 1930 qui examinent tous les aspects
du lac, il est donc vraiment remarquable si
quelque chose a existé et n'a pas été
détecté par tous leurs échantillonnages au cours de
toutes ces décennies
étrangères
les sceptiques disent que c'est peu probable mais
personne n'a prouvé Au-delà de tout
doute raisonnable qu'il n'y a rien là-bas qu'ils
ne peuvent pas faire que le lac est beaucoup trop grand pour
eux qu'il
s'agit d'un très vieux lac c'est une ancienne
pièce d'eau il s'est formé 13
000  il y a des années euh
c'est très profond
par endroits c'est plus de 200 pieds de profondeur
donc il peut bien y avoir des choses au
fond de l'eau qui ne sont pas encore
expliquées
est
[Musique]
bonjour [
Musique]
bonus
[Musique]
Je crois qu'il peut y avoir  bien être une
créature étrange dans le lac j'aimerais que je ne vois aucun
mal à croire au folklore et à la légende
je pense que le folklore est très important pour une
région
[la musique]
avant 2006 le bonus ne faisait pas partie de nos
vies
et puis il y avait  les premières observations
et bien sûr avec la première vue vous
étiez très sceptique puis il y en a une autre
je pense que jusqu'à présent il y a eu huit
observations de bonusi Astic
charm
[Musique]
c'est principalement des visiteurs britanniques des gens de
l'Extrême-Orient et dans une moindre proportion
des gens du Nord  Amérique États-Unis
et Canada et aussi des gens de France
et de Belgique et de Hollande et de Scandinavie Le
tourisme est extrêmement important pour le
parc national du Lake District chaque année,
environ 15 millions de visiteurs viennent dans le
parc national, il maintient l'emploi
environ 15
000 emplois équivalents temps plein dans le tourisme
et la valeur du tourisme dans le
parc national du Lake District, quelque part dans la
région d'un milliard de livres, donc c'est
incroyablement important. Je ne peux pas vraiment dire
combien de ces visiteurs viennent dans la
région à la recherche de bonassi, bien sûr que certains d'entre
eux le font, mais je pense probablement  la grande
majorité vient pour le
paysage spectaculaire et les expériences des visiteurs véritablement de classe mondiale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une chose que le Lake District n'est pas,
c'est Disney World, vous savez, les gens viennent
ici pour le paysage des montagnes
et des lacs, mais ils  venez aussi
voir Bonesty, vous savez que j'ai quatre hôtels
avec 150 chambres à moi et nous demandons à
nos clients pourquoi ils viennent ici et
de plus en plus d'entre eux disent que nous
venons ici pour des bonusi comme une coïncidence
aujourd'hui c'est le premier  la fois où on m'a déjà
demandé c'est une famille chinoise et
ils ont montré qu'ils avaient un livre touristique chinois
en chinois avec une photo de
ce qu'ils appellent était censé être le
Neti et il m'a demandé si je savais quelque chose
à ce sujet alors mais c'est  la première fois qu'on m'a
demandé
bonusa n'est pas une attraction touristique dans le
sens où vous savez que les gens viennent monter
en bonus ou que les gens viennent voir
des jouets bonesty ils viennent voir bonessi sur le
lac bien sûr ils peuvent acheter un bonus  jouet
ainsi qu'un souvenir mais la vraie
attraction de Brunei est la chance de
voir des bonusi émerger des profondeurs de
l'eau Je
dois garder les yeux pâles dites-moi comme
vos enfants mettent les pieds dans l'eau J'ai
un bonus ils peuvent être en train de grignoter leur
tootsies et ce genre de choses, alors nous
essayons de les intéresser un peu et de
les intéresser et ils se
joignent au plaisir et je pense que cela
ajoute juste un peu de plaisir à leur voyage
peut-être qu'ils le diront  les amis peut-être que ça
deviendra un peu un mythe et une
légende et peut-être que ça
passera le mot comme
ça
et ils aiment toutes sortes d'
histoires folkloriques, ils aiment ce genre de contes
et ils semblent être vraiment tombés amoureux
des histoires sur Bon Essie aussi
[Musique]
il y a maintenant
euh un livre d'histoires pour les enfants sur l'os
SC et c'est très populaire et pendant
l'été  Je comprends que pas mal
de visiteurs japonais et chinois sont allés sur
un sentier qui a été mis en place principalement
pour les enfants en fait, mais
euh les visiteurs japonais et chinois adultes
sont allés sur l'os Essie Trail, donc
je pense qu'ils sont curieux
[Musique  ]
nous venons de Chine et nous venons ici pour
étudier à Lancaster donc nous voyageons ici pour
passer un
week-end de vacances
nous essayons d'acheter les billets là-bas
afin que nous puissions écouter les
histoires mystérieuses ici donc nous sommes B semble très
intéressant je pense
étranger
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
merci
[Musique]
la plupart des Japonais viennent à cause de
Beatrix Potter et de Peter Rabbit mais les
Chinois viennent à cause de bonessi
ils veulent voir le dragon britannique
Je pense que c'est très intéressant que
euh dans  l'histoire ancienne des Chinois
et l'histoire ancienne de l'Angleterre il y a
un lien commun les dragons font partie de notre
culture nationale et ils font partie de la
culture nationale chinoise ils sont
célébrés chaque nouvelle année et dans un sens
les Britanniques avaient commencé à  oubliez les
dragons maintenant le bonus est en arrière-plan cela
nous rappelle que les dragons font partie de
notre culture
oh oh
de fois par an peut-être
trois fois par an si nous le pouvons et nous
pensons juste que c'est beau c'est beau et
les enfants adorent ça et c'est l'air frais
et et vous savez le beau paysage
nous ne connaissons vraiment aucun monstre
ici j'ai  jamais vu de toute façon mais nous
regardons toujours quand nous sommes sur
les bateaux mais nous ne l'avons pas encore fait c'est
juste un peu amusant n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
étranger
nous avons un petit écran SC en os sur
le  mur et nous avons quelques petits liens
bonus en peluche, des livres à colorier
et des morceaux qui suscitent l'intérêt des
touristes, ils n'ont peut-être jamais entendu parler
de l'os SC jusqu'à ce qu'ils entrent dans le magasin
, puis ils voient les
tracés de journaux que nous avons sur le mur et
ils nous demanderont ce que c'est que tout ce
truc d'os SC et nous leur en avons parlé
nous avons une petite blague et disons
bien si vous devez faire attention quand
vous êtes sur le lac Windermere vous ne savez jamais en
direct
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
cela permet de vivre l'aventure
à une échelle assez petite que les gens qui
pourraient rêver des Alpes et de l'
Himalaya mais savent qu'ils n'atteindront jamais
le sommet d'une montagne là-bas, ils peuvent
réaliser quelque chose ici avec un
effort relativement modeste qu'ils peuvent obtenir  au sommet d'
une ascension assez difficile en quelques
heures et voir les vues les plus spectaculaires
et c'est à la portée de tous, il s'agit de
réaliser et de réaliser des rêves
étrangers
[La musique]
amène des touristes à Windermere et
au parc national dans son ensemble, je pense en  dans
les années à venir, les bonusi pourraient devenir aussi gros
que
Nessie en Écosse,
pourquoi pas il doit avoir un membre de sa famille
quelque part au Royaume-Uni, alors pourquoi pas à
Windermere
[Musique]
Je ne pense pas que vous seriez pleinement humain
si vous ne trouviez pas  vous ici et vous
vous retrouvez debout au bord
du lac et regardant dehors et pensant que
vous savez qu'il y a vraiment quelque chose là-dedans
[Musique]
tout ce que les gens ne peuvent pas comprendre à
quoi que ce soit que les gens craignent
n'importe quel Mystique toute mention de monstres
attire toujours
le public  maintenant ici dans le Lake District,
nous sommes déjà une base touristique établie,
c'est l'une des plus belles
régions du Royaume-Uni Sinon en Europe et
certainement sinon dans le monde,
c'est une mini Suisse, c'est une mini
Rocheuses, c'est une mini Alpes, il a
tout là-bas il y a les quatre saisons
tu as ton printemps tu as ton
été tu as ton automne tu as
ton hiver qui apporte les neiges chaque
saison est une terre différente quand tu regardes
de l'autre côté du lac et pas deux jours quand je
descends ici ou je  Je nage ici, il n'y a pas
deux jours pareils et la beauté
du Lake District est ce
paysage changeant qui change l'atmosphère et
c'est tout simplement magnifique maintenant des bonusi qui
arrivent qui attireraient d'autres personnes
pour leurs propres avantages pour voir ce qu'il y a là-
bas ça peut  ne soyez pas de mal et ce qu'il fait, il
attire les gens dans cette belle
région, je crois qu'il y a un monstre là-
bas, beaucoup ne le font pas
et ils résoudraient probablement
le mystère des bonusi mais je suis un
croyant les bonus là-bas et il est
là en profitant  le magnifique Lake
District comme nous le faisons tous
[Musique]
merci
[Musique] étranger
étranger
[Musique]